welcome back everyone to round three of
the dubai rapid tournament
if you saw my first two recap videos
you'll know that i beat a
1200 about in the first round a 1400 in
the second round
this game i'm playing a player rated uh
just over 1900
by the name of ramez s
and i actually found my opponent's
chess.com username
right before the game began and i had
very very little time to do opening
preparation
but i saw my opponent
typically plays the four night scotch
in the move order like this
and goes for d4
and
i was debating before the game um do i
play
a sicilian or do i try and
stick with my kind of dubious online
gambit repertoire
and go for a stafford
now i knew my opponent wouldn't go into
like a normal stafford because after e45
knife three knight f6
um my opponent doesn't take but rather
plays knight c3
aiming for a four night scotch
and uh
i decided before the game i would go for
this position and play bishop to c5
and this is the position that we reached
in the game
now the point of bishop c5 is to try and
transpose
into a staffer gambit after takes
knight c6
takes and takes
and i know this is a dubious and risky
opening to play
especially otb but i was ready to go
into it and um
i was playing someone who i suspected
didn't know who i was like a lot of
other people were like coming up to me
and um at least mentioning that they've
seen my videos but this uh this opponent
didn't
and we we got to this position my
opponent took the pawn
i played knight c6
and my opponent did not take on c6
but rather thought for a little bit
and
played knight to d3
a couple backstories about this position
uh first of all i've had this position
against none other than
magnus carlsen on the chess
i'll leave a link below to that video um
it was a stream game it was actually the
last time i played magnus as a lead
chess title arena magnus moved back to
f3
and got just a much better position i
tried d5 but after takes
takes
and d4 white is doing quite well up a
pawn there's not so much compensation
for black
so
this move order it's very risky to play
because there's
there's a bunch of different ways white
can get the advantage between taking
or going back
um but i played this with the
the hope of getting something a bit more
dynamic and interesting and exciting
maybe trapping my opponent
and my opponent here played knight to d3
which leads me to another backstory
this is the same position i had in this
video where i played dina balancaya
sochi russia oh my god what's that
oh so you're not familiar with the
stafford gambit
well that doesn't sound fun i actually
have not watched the staff again there's
a rule in chess when you're up material
you should trade
okay then i will not oh
and in that video she didn't know what
the stafford was and she kind of
stumbled into this it turns out knight
d3 is a completely fine move even though
it looks awkward it blocks a pawn which
blocks the bishop it attacks by bishop
so it keeps some initiative
and it turns out to be somewhat solid
for white i play bishop d4 a same move i
play against tina
and then after bishop e2
i believe against dina i played h5 which
has intention of really going for the
quick attack
i realized here that h5 could very
simply be met with h3 and i wanted to
castle and not weaken my kingside so i
decided to castle right away
idea to get the rook to e-file as soon
as possible try and win back upon
my opponent castle back i played rook e8
and here i'm already guaranteeing to win
back the pawn
because i have two attackers there's
only one defender and this violent c3 i
can remove at any moment so here my
opponent plays bishop to f3
and forces me to make a decision if i
actually want to regain the pawn
because if i take on c3
i'm
conceding the bishop pair i'm also
helping light develop
and i thought this position
even though i regain the pawn it would
be difficult to play for a win just
given that white has very easy play
things could simplify a bit more
white has a slight but very stable edge
and i thought it was a better practical
decision for me to keep my bishop on d4
and see how white is going to develop
this bishop given that the knight is a
bit stuck on d3
and it's not clear how white will
actually complete development
so i decided to play d6
now this did give white time to defend
the pawn even more
and i play a6 so
i am
just down a clean pawn here
and as we're in the sea over the next
few moves i really didn't get any
compensation
i took a decent amount of time before
playing a6 i was looking for other like
aggressive ideas i really wanted to play
this move and go over some eventual
like night attacking ideas but this just
allows takes takes in d3
and again there's really not much for
black
so a6
it was somewhat of an admission that i
don't have much but it was also a
waiting move seeing what white is up to
opponent plays knight d5
going for some trade also enabling c3
i played bishop a7
c3
and now i'm knight d7
so here i'm kind of just going out of my
way to avoid trades
also trying to get my knight here and
maybe try and get the bishop pair which
is actually what happened after
pawn g3
knight ce5 enabling some idea of c6
we trade
and here my opponent played d4
i should note here that if bishop g2 an
attempt to save the bishop pair
this would be very risky because after
knight d3
here black is probably getting a nice uh
at least some nice compensation so
d4 was played
i took the bishop
queen takes
and i was not so happy with the outcome
of the opening
i gambled upon i didn't really get any
compensation
white is clearly clearly better here
and now we're gonna see hopefully some
instructive moments in how to try and
recover
from just a bad position
and the first step was just to try and
cut my losses and keep the position as
tense as possible so i really didn't
want to simplify or trade down
where it makes the position easier to
play i start with a move c6 kick away
the knight
and then queen a5
trying to apply some pressure and create
some scenarios where there's uh there's
tactical possibilities
uh one idea with queen a5 is to pin the
c3 pawn because now the the rook is is
undefended on e1
and there's some potential idea to
eventually take
although i'm not really threatening to
take in this position let's imagine
white just plays a waiting move like h4
if i do take this runs into b4
and then i'm just losing uh more
material
so queen a5 it didn't have an immediate
tactical threat
but
just trying to apply pressure
pullman played bishop d2
and again i really wanted to take now
the bishop's undefended but again b4
and i'm sure my opponent saw this
so
i tried to keep being patient i played
bishop to d7 my opponent plays knight d3
very solid move
and uh kept trying to improve rook 88
and here my opponent played what was
probably his uh one of his biggest
mistakes of the game white should really
just be patient here
a move like a4 or b4 even h4 ideas of
gradually
expanding on the king side instead my
opponent was maybe a bit too
rushed in trying to to force matters
and play the move e5
and at first this move looks very
sensible attempts to
trade a bit on e-file potentially get
the knight to e5 to target f7 and the
bishop
but the drawback of this move
is it's very weakening to the light
squares
and once e5 is played this bishop has a
lot more potential in the position
given most of white's pawns are in dark
squares meaning the light squares are
very very exploitable on top of that
white doesn't have a light for a bishop
so e5 is a very anti-positional move
and i was happy to trade after takes
takes
takes takes
it seems like white's the one making
progress but after bishop e6
the tables are beginning to turn
and i defend the pawn i'm ready to play
bishop d5
and on top of that i now have a tactical
threat
which my opponent missed
um opponent played a3
probably attempting to uh try and get
the rook in but after a3 this is a
another another blunder
and now it's black to move and win
material now i'm hoping most people
watching have been paying attention
and
listen to what i said earlier of what i
was trying to do tactically
exploit the pin against the c pawn in
this position i can finally do so and
take on d4
and the problem for white is that b4 no
longer works
even though it would hit the queen and
break the pin
it would leave the knights available for
capture
and i would be very happy here actually
i believe
black is winning more material because
the bishop and rook are attacked yeah
rick diwan walks into a pin and also
walks into a skewer bishop g4 would be
game over
so
once i played bishop d4
i was breathing a sigh of relief given
that i won back the pawn and
white's position from here on out uh
kind of just continued to crumble
uh pawn takes d4 is played
i take on d2
hitting two undefended pawns
not to mention at this point there is
already some time pressure
opponent i think was falling below two
minutes now we were playing with a five
second increment so the game did last a
bit longer queen c3 was played
i scoop up another pawn
knight f3 i do get forked but i'm not
losing material because after it takes
takes i then save the rook
and i'm actually the one delivering the
effective fork
winning another pawn
and i went from having really bad
position down upon to entering the end
game
up two pawns and it didn't take too much
effort to convert this position
after rook b1 i played bishop to d5
and i loudly said oh no my pawn
and my opponent didn't actually take and
i didn't say oh no my pawn but if
white does take there is maiden one
for this reason my opponent played pawn
h4
i played pawn g6
again i could say oh no my pawn
but if white takes it's made in two this
time
so after g6
unfortunately i don't remember the rest
of the game
and i wasn't able to find the
dgt broadcast of this round but
thankfully uh
got to a point where the position was
pretty straightforward to convert
opponent fought on for a bit longer but
eventually i scooped up
the
a pawn and
made way on the queen side
to take home another point in the
tournament
so this put me to three out of three now
the final story i want to share about
this game
is afterwards my opponent came up to me
and asked me if i had just mistakenly
blundered in the opening with bishop to
c5 and
and if this was just an oversight by me
and little did my opponent know that
this this was an intentional gambit
but based on the way the opening went it
uh kind of did feel like a blunder in
hindsight
given that uh it was not an opening
success
but it was a success coming back from a
bad position now you won't want to miss
the next round i play yet another
fun and dubious gambit in round four
stay tuned for that recap video be sure
to like and subscribe it does motivate
me to work on these videos
at a faster pace
and i'll see you in the next video
stay tuned